Thanks to KiwiCo for supporting this episode
of Journey to the Microcosmos!
Click the link in the description to learn
more and for a special offer.
We’re often running into examples of endosymbiosis
in the microcosmos, like this partnership
between Paramecium bursaria and the green
algae Chlorella.
The algae lives inside the paramecium, providing
sustenance derived from its own photosynthetic
machinery in exchange for protection from
viruses that linger outside the living borders
of the paramecium.
This is one of those heartwarming tales of
the microcosmos.
One small organism finds another even smaller
organism, collaborating to create a better
life for each.
But not all tales of internalized organisms
are so peaceful, and not all creatures found
inside a paramecium are welcome guests.
This, for reference, is a healthy paramecium.
You can see the round, healthy nuclei towards
the center of the organism.
And this is another paramecium.
It looks similar to the one we just saw, only
now the nuclei are filled with strange bumps.
From some angles, one of the nuclei looks
almost as if it’s full of crystals.
Except those aren’t crystals.
When James, our Master of Microscopes came
upon this frosted-looking nucleus, he recognized
it from a paper he’d read three years before
- a paper that contained a photo of a paramecium
whose nucleus was filled with needle-like
bacteria called Holospora.
Holospora were first described by Waldemar
Haffkine in 1890.
He’d been studying Paramecium caudatum when
he noticed these parasitic organisms residing
in the nucleus.
Through his investigation, Haffkine would
end up identifying three species: Holospora
obtusa, Holospora undulata, and Holospora
elegans.
While his work would prove important to establishing
the existence of these bacteria, Haffkine
soon moved onto other research interests.
This pivot would put a temporary pause to
Holospora discovery, but it would pay off
in other ways: Haffkine would go on to create
vaccines against both cholera and the plague.
So, you know, not bad.
Today, there are nine species known to us.
They differ not just in appearance, but in
where they infect their hosts.
In some cases, certain species will live in
a paramecium’s macronucleus, while others
prefer the micronucleus.
And some Holospora species may also only target
specific Paramecium species, while others
will infect more indiscriminately.
But the process of infection is a shared one.
It begins with getting eaten.
The paramecium may just be casually munching
on its surroundings when they end up phagocytosing
some of the Holospora, which then end up in
the ciliate’s food vacuoles.
The bacteria aren’t motile, meaning they
can’t move on their own.
But within an hour of getting into the paramecium,
these surprising escape artists will make
their way out of the vacuole, which is good
for them because everything in there is going
to get digested and use the paramecium’s
own systems to get into their nucleus of choice.
How do they choose their target nucleus?
We do not know.
But when they get there, the Holospora invade.
At this infectious point in their lives, the
Holospora are shaped like rods and will be
around 10-20 microns long.
But once they’ve settled into their nuclear
homes, the trespassing bacteria switch modes,
shortening to about 1-3 microns long.
They also begin reproducing, dividing and
filling up the nucleus with more and more
of their own kind until the time comes to
infect a new paramecium.
In general, parasites have two choices when
it comes to widening their infectious net:
horizontal transmission or vertical transmission.
For horizontal transmission, the parasite
has to leave their current host to find a
new one, but for vertical transmission, the
parasite just waits for their host to reproduce
so they can infect the new offspring.
Each method of transmission comes with its
own set of advantages and disadvantages.
Horizontal transmission, for example, is great
if you’re an organism that wants to make
as much use as possible out of your host,
but you do run the risk of potentially killing
them in the process.
Meanwhile, vertical transmission involves
waiting for your host to reproduce and then
infecting the new offspring.
This might be less risky than venturing out
into the unknown to find a new home.
But it will require both delicacy and patience,
ensuring that you take just enough advantage
of your host to survive, but not so much that
your host cannot survive long enough to replicate.
Different parasites balance the choice between
these transmission styles based on a number
of conditions, but the Holospora can actually
switch between horizontal and vertical transmission
based on how the paramecium seems to be doing.
After it infects a new paramecium and
switches to its reproductive stage, the Holospora
will keep doubling and doubling inside the
nucleus.
And if the paramecium is growing rapidly,
then it will be dividing a lot into daughter
cells, and with each division of the ciliate,
the bacteria will be distributed between the
daughter cells as well.
This is vertical transmission, and it works
great for Holospora….unless the paramecium’s
growth starts to slow down, at which point
the bacteria will switch back to their infectious
form and leave the host to find a new home.
The Holospora can’t survive outside their
host, so this is the one time they will leave
the safe confines of the paramecium.
Despite Holospora’s infectious nature and
paramecium’s prevalence around the world,
it’s actually kind of difficult to find
Holospora-infected paramecium out in the wild.
They’ve only been documented in the Northern
hemisphere, and even then, sightings can be infrequent.
So it was actually pretty exciting to find
them in our samples, even if it means our
paramecium are dealing with an unwelcome guest.
Paramecium have developed various strategies
to prevent Holospora infection.
Some can’t ingest the infectious forms,
while others seem capable of blocking the
bacteria from entering the cytoplasm or nucleus.
And given that infection by Holospora has
been associated with lower rates of sexual
reproduction and other abnormalities in the
host, it makes sense that the paramecium would
evolve a defense.
However, there have been cases where a particular
species of Holospora will infect a particular
species of paramecium, and the host actually
benefits from the interaction.
In one case, the host was better able to survive
abrupt changes in temperature, and in another,
it was able to withstand changes in osmotic
pressure.
But this is not a universal experience, it
depends on the combination of host and parasite.
It’s hard not to look at all of this from
the paramecium’s point of view, to not see
this as a larger organism that finds itself
contending with microbial invaders.
But the Holospora is also just trying to survive
as well, in the one world it knows how to survive in.
If only that world wasn’t another organism.
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you again to KiwiCo for supporting
this episode.
KiwiCo creates super cool hands-on projects
for kids that make learning fun!
With a KiwiCo subscription, each month the
kid in your life will receive a fun, engaging
new project which will help develop their
creativity and confidence!
They have eight subscription lines, each catering
to different age groups and topics, and each
box comes with ALL the supplies needed for
that month’s project meaning you won’t
have to make any extra trips to the store.
In their Tinker Crate, intended for ages 9
and up, you can get your very own robotics
kit and use it to build an actual walking
robot!
These projects are a great resource for learning
at home and offer fantastic hands-on activities
to balance the overload of screen time from
virtual classes or video chats, and KiwiCo
also has a Store that allows you the flexibility
of purchasing individual projects with no
subscription needed!
So head on over to kiwico.com/microcosmos
and use the code “microcosmos” or click
the link in the description to get 20% off
everything on the site.
Thank you, as always, to our patrons, all
of the people on the screen right now.
You are the people that keep this show happening.
We love that you love what we do, and we love
you for it.
If you want to be one of those people and
support this show, you can go to Patreon.com/journeytomicro
If you want to see more from our Master of
Microscopes James, check out Jam & Germs on
Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there’s
very likely a subscribe button somewhere nearby.